Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to what might just be the
...last episode, of Five Night's at Freddy's: VR
Now those that have stars, wait a minute. That was the big question about last time.
Also, what does that button do? I have no idea, but
...there are stars here and there are no stars there.
And I'm not 100% sure why, but that...
That was that, wait.
I'm telling you, that, that is that.
The colors are slightly different but it's still that.
So ALL that matters is going into the end...
...with a little bit of bravery...
...and a little bit of HUtzpAh.
I've got HUtzpAH.
I've got bravery!
I've got all the above!
So this is the mama-cham-bah...
...this is the big buh-kahuna.
Here we go. Teleport? Teleport.
I guess this did
I guess this did take the place of the Five Nights at Freddy's 4 one, but I don't know...
Don't be late?
Wait WHAT?-
Wait, I'm sorry
I'm sorry, what?
Do-
Don't be late?
What does that mean?
Is it still in that room?
Oh shit.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm ready.
Whatd'ya got for me?
HUH?
Find...
What the fuck?
Oh, do you trust me-
This way.
Ah?
...Oh.
Oh.
Oh, I have to pick-
Oh, where's Freddy?
Where's Freddy, huh?
Oh..
Find me this way...
Do you trust me?
YeeeAaa!
Yea, I do.
I-I do.
You know what, I do trust you!
I do.
I do trust you...
Huh?
Which'n way?
He's coming.
Eh oO, shit-
Oh
Oh.
OH.
Oh, hi!
Ooooh!
Hi!
Um...
👀
Oo!
Wha-
Ho, HEY!
OH
HI
UM
Okay, heeeEEEY...
How you doin'?
WOOOOO BOY!
They're ready for you.
[Jumpscare Warning]
T-ohhh, fuck.
Okay, um..
Alright, interesting-
[Jumpscare Warning]
Not this...
DONT TOUCH ME...alright.
Sohohoho...
Alright so, um...
Interesting?
Very interesting.
Imma go- Imma go this way.
You know, just cuz.
For shit and giggles...
What's this way, huh?
Oh, fffrick.
Oh frick!
Find the path. Oh, frick!
What is- Are you lost?
A lil bit,
yeah.
A little bit- This way?
Um..
O.k...
Am I lost? a little bit, yeah. How about this one?
Oh!
Hey, I found a way!
I think?
Huh..
Are you still comin?
Oh, so I found the path? But not the right path.
Hang on a second, okay you're on the way now...
Hey you- You come cloooser
Come cloooser, come clooser, come clooser.
[Jumpscare Warning]
Okay, cool, alright that's fine.
That's fine, cuz that's, that's fine,
That's nothin', that ain't nothin',
because there...
There's somethin' here.
Because what if in here theres a secret that needs to be found?
"Find the path.", you say.
Well, i'm gonna FIND the path.
Uh-huh, you can count on THAT!
There's nothin' special here, I can't go back...
So- Woah.
How 'bout this one?
Oh shi- Woo, oh OH FUCK
Oh, OH SHIT!
Oh, dohh shit, okay..
Well I goofed this big-ly...
Why are you everywhere? This golden rabbit.
Wait a minute..
The rab- Wait
The rabbit.
Not this way- Ooh.
Whoah hohohohohohh.
Hii.
How aRe YOu?
HuAugh, can i hElp you?
Uh-oh.
Woah, uh-oh uh-oh Uh-Oh
No, no, NO, NO!
[Jumpscare warning]
There you are, okay...
This uh, whole episode is just gonna be findin' the jumpscares.
[Jumpscare Warning]
Like this one!
"Remember Jeremy." I will not.
SCREW you, Jeremy!
Okay, so..
...If I'm guessing this right...
...And if it's correct i'll just go quickly to the other one.
If i'm guessing this right...
...If i go down here...
To the end one, it's gonna loop back to that hallway.
No- Fuck, what?
What the- NOT this way?
Not this way..?- Oh, oh god.
Am I about to die- Why am I in Five Nights at Fred-
Hi...
Okay, um...
This way? Or that way?-
What is- What- Where AM I then?
Ooh.
"Sorry! out of order." What?
NUH UHH.
Nah, don't lie to me.
Oh my god.
[Mini Jumpscare Warning]
Oh,
OH, hi-
[blabbering]
Favorite flavor?
VANILLA!
Choc-oh-lat?
A lot of choc-oh-lat, I like a lot of choc-oh-lat- I'm gonna die, aren't I?
I dunno which way im going, CHOC-OH-LAT?
Oh shit- Okay, so we're just loopin' around.
Oh, funk-a-licious.
okay wait- I'm gonna go...
Okay, there you are.
Okay..
So this is interesting, so just-
The other one's like, uh..
Okay, that's definitely out of order, I can't go that way again.
But what's THIS way?
Oh.
ohh, This way- Not great, not there...
Not where?
Not what?
And not why?
Great, GREAT. I like great.
Find- Ughh. Okay, so i'm back at the beginning.
Verry interesting.
Okay, VERRY interesting.
VeRy iNterEsTInG
Oh shit.
Okay, so that's that.
Which is fine, because if I keep going...
I'm not gonna have to worry about it, right?
Oh, and I'm back here. So that's extremely out of order.
This is this.
This goes here...
[Jumpscare Warning]
AH, FUA-FUCKING OKAY.
GOD.
[Jumpscare Warning]
This goes here... so..
Great...
Not here, not there, this way, what about this one? E?
Okay, i'm still alive- Oh shit!
Oh, ˢʰᶦᵗ
Can I go there? no.
OH Fuck.
HOOH, FUCK.
HOOH, SHIT.
HI?
Hello?
Ooh, fuc- Don't like that, okay.. uhh...
Exit? Exit?
Exit? um, this one?
Shit.
Hooh, shit.
Where is this, what the hell?
Oh my god.
Oh my god- Four?
Oh shit, that's not good. This way?
[Cheery elevator music]
What's happening?
OOOOOOooh...
HelLoOoh?
I'm gon' go, excuse me, sorry, out of order door.
Ohh, shi- WHERE AM I?
There's that bunny, that bunny keeps show-
WHA- WHOAH, WHOAH, HI.
Ohh fuck.
Okay you got pizza, huh?
Favorite?
Hooh, frick. Flavor?
I dunno.
I don't- I'm guessing-
Oh shit- I'm guessing that's a clue.
So left is probably the correct way...
But I'mma go pepperoni.
Okay, so I'm back here. God dammit- Okay.
Where's the bunny- You're that way, so
it would suggest that that is leading me to the-
"correct path".
If-If I'm...
...right about that, that's what it do.
And that's what it's all about- So if the bunny is.. right there...
"Do you trust me?" not, not-not even remotely... At all.
So that's closing there.
So what happens if I go here?
Okay, back here, huh?
Oh vent- Oh shit.
I didn't know there was... A vent..Here.
Uh- Ooh, oh!
Coin!
Hey!
Yayy!
I guess I should probably-
There's probably hiddens around here everywhere.
I should probably look up that guide again because I bet that one of the tapes is here too.
I don't see the bunny.
Wait a minute- This is the room to the other side!
Wait a minute! This is the other side of the room!
That way!
Oh yeah it does- Okay, that's...
So it is kinda logical...
Okay, so...
I-uh
[Jumpscare Warning]
WHAT THE FUCK WAS-
What the fuck was that?!
What the fuck was that?
What was that?
I've never seen that before in my life!
It was like a red shmear with eyes!
[Jumpscare Warning]
What was that?
Oh...Goddammit! How do I keep getting back here.
Okay, that goes there!
This goes here!
Okay so it is a set path, it is not random.
It is definitely not random.
It is definitely not random!
[Jumpscare Warning]
So....
AH FUCK WHAT IS THAT?! WHAT IS THAT!
What is that?!
Some weird red glowy Freddy?
I dunno, got this.
Okay, this is fine. This. Is. Fine.
I believe it's this one.
That one.
Correct? Yes! Okay.
We're here...uh...
There's some sodies there and you go for the pizza. Which is fine...
So, since you're on that side, I'm guessing that one!
Oh shit...goddammit!
Really?
Really!?...
Okay, alright
Whe-Where does this one go again?
I don't remember, I'm just doing this so I can have everything-
This goes all the way back to FNAF 1.
Okay!
So this one goes to here...
That one goes to the three doors.
This one goes to...
the elevator room.
This one...
is out of order now.
Well, then, what do I-
"This way"?
"Do you trust me?" Uh not really. Okay
Not really...
Oh... I knew I shouldn't have trusted you.
Okay, where does that lead?
I don't know.
Here, alright good
Woah, what the fuck?
Wait, what?
Wait, what the fuck?
That wasn't a door-HOOO Fuck!
What? HOH Shit! um...
Oh fuck!...
What the fuck?
Is there a secret here or something?
What is this?
Oh god! Um...I don't see anything so I'm just gonna go
Oh fuck, "What goes up?"
I don't know?.... Air?
Me?
I-What are you talking about?
Oh fucking shit, are you kidding me?
Oh god, what goes up?
OH SHIT. YES!
What goes up? Me!
I go up.
Oh fuck?
Oh fuck!
Oh!
Oh.
Hi.
Uh
Oh boy, can I have this?
Do you mind?
Thank you!
What the fuck?
Oh shit. Um.
OH. FUCKING HI. UH.
Okay!...?
Y-Y-You two okay with that?
Whatever that was?
You're alright with that?
Okay- Just let me- Hang on.
(I'm) Hungry.
All that running and screaming, really...
did a number on me!
Can I have more of this?
Okay... Happy Birthday!...
How'd you know, it's my biRTHDAY!...
It's my birthday!...
Okay, good! Okay, I guess I'll...
go here then.
OOOO
Yes, please!
Oh shit, okay. That's- what the fuck.
What?
No!
No..!
Uh.
But-
[singing]
Okay!...
Thanks!
What about that?
Okay.
[Mark and Narrator simultaneously]: Bye Bye!
Narrator: Take care now.
Buh bye!
Buh bye.
But-
Oh-Hi. How'ya doing there?
Um...so....
Uh
Glitchtrap: Can you hear me?
But-
Glitchtrap: Hello...
Um excuse me I'm just gonna be here for a moment!
Um.
Tape 15- You there? Okay good.
privacy...
I don't.
Well, y'know, it's a little late for that!
Um...little bit late!
Uh...can't
Can't really explain how FUTILE that is NOW.
Uh I don't have all of the tapes.
There's nothing behind here.
So um...
Little problem with that!
Is that I've a-
Tha-Tha-That came last.
That came- uh well second last anyway.
That wasn't quite last.
Um!...
BUT....
I'm still missing one tape.
Now where...
could a tape, such as that, be?
Is the question!
Where would that be!
"(Go to) Gallery" Wait.
OH.
OH!
Hello? WOooo
Yay, thank you.
Okay, disappointment. That's-That's great.
Um.
Okay?
Uh..
Is there...
Can't remember here and there was one...here.
I'm gonna bump my head, aren't I?
Nothing there.
Okay, nothing there.
Um.
Alright.
Uh.
Anything behind this?
There's nothing in here.
Definitely not.
oop
Oh, well, there we go!
There she blows, got all the tapes now!
Uh, so that's
I don't know what t-
Heyyyy.
Oh wow, that's a slow reload.
Okay, Hi.
This is great.
I love that this is here!
Uh, not sure what I'm supposed to do with it.
This is just horrible!
This is a horrible peep show!
[Imitating Toy Freddy]
"Toy Freddy": Faster!
"Toy Freddy": FASTER!
Mark: I can't go any fa-
"Toy Freddy": FASTER
"Toy Freddy": FAST [indecipherable blabbering]
Mark: I can't, I-
Okay, thank you for that!...
What are those? Wait. What are those?
Wait, Wha?
When were you in..ANYWHERE?
Wait.
When were you anywhere?
W-When were you anywhere and what are you!?
When-When were either of you-
anywhere!
When were- Where were YOUUU
WHERE WERE
YOUUUU.
Where were you?
I have no idea where were you. It doesn't make any sense.
This doesn't make none sense!
This is nonsensical!
This is a bunch of nonsense!
Oh, it's you, LOLBIT.
Alright, whatever. Goodbye! I'm going back to menu.
I gotta assemble a (rabbit?)
Apparently. Hello?
Hey, who's got a tummy!
Boop!
Boop! Boop!
Okay, alright.
Glitchtrap: Can you hear me?
Sorry, my vision just went (?)
Glitchtrap: Hello...
One moment please!
Glitchtrap: Can you hear me?
Hello.
Ah, give me a second!
Just gotta
real quick!
Gotta listen to- you back there? Good.
Okay, here we go!
Boinkus.
Sure.
[sarcastically] Great. Love that.
Wait. Hang on, don't love it as much.
Uh wait.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh. How 'bout now!
Now? Right when I get out there.
Probably right immediately away.
Okay.
What happens if it merges with me?
Hello?
Play the music huh.
Play the music. Huh.
So is that the switch?
Is this the switch?
Huh?
...at the prize counter.
Minding my own business. Oh no. I dropped something
Hope no one tries to merge with me.
Uh, anybody here want to merge with me?
Oh! Hi! Hello. Hi, how are you?
Uh, Showtime?
Uh...Stranger Danger!
Hi.
Hello.
May I merge with you?
Glitchtrap: Can you hear me?
Can you help me? Are you help-able?
Glitchtrap: Hello...
Hello!
'Kay how 'bout in nightmare land?
Would you like to merge?
No? Okay, alright, well.
Okay...
In here maybe?
Hello?
'Kay not in here.
Weird. Um. I don't know...
Do I need to get the coins or something?
Woah. Shit. Hi. Okay. Hi. Uh.
You merging, huh?
You merging! Huh?
Well x3
How 'bout, is this the switch?
Or is that the switch?
Showtime?
Oh shit!
Oh...
shit!
I didn't- I tried to push-
Wait.
Wait, what?
[Jumpscare Warning]
What?
I didn't know which one I wanted.
OH! The switch!
Like, as in that-Ohhh.
Like, as in very clearly that
Uh yeah yeah that makes a lot of sense.
Okay, you know what, actually, that-
that was my bad.
That was my bad.
Oh hey!
Begin the process and flip the switch.
Flip the switch.
Flip the switch!
Flip the swi
Flip the flappy-
What?
Hi. What the fuck?
What was that? What happened?
Did I do it?
I did it, didn't I?
I win. I'm good.
Okay, I don't know why that.
Glitchtrap: Hello...
Hello! Hi um.
Ok so I'm missing something here. I accidentally went into Nightmare Mode.
Flip the switch?
What does that mean?
Flip the switch.
Prize counter?
This one?
Get out.
Get in.
Maybe I'm doing it too early. I think must be doing a little- a hair too early.
So I gotta wait until the process starts and then flip it!
I'm a good switch flipper! I just gotta switch flip at the right mom(ent).
Kay now- Uh no, you tricky. You tricky but you're not gonna trick me that good.
'Cause I'm coming right back for youuu!
Here we go. Merge!
No, okay, well that's not fun.
Or fair!
'Kay, you're there.
So it's starting the process right about there.
Right there!
OO!
Oh! Hi! Hello!
How are you?
Uh, you...
I was gonna be quiet.
Is it because I shout all the time?
Where you goin?
Where are you going, bubba?
Uh what?
Wait. Woah what the fuck?
Hi?
Okay?
Hello? Are you still gonna be there--
Oh. Hi!
???: Hey.
??: It's me! With the melty eyes!
???: Shouldn't have taken all the LSD huh?
Mark: Well, I mean, it was kinda forcibly injected into me and all that food I ate-
Mark: Wait, the food I ate?!
???: yEeAaH I've been (reaching?) my code into you.
???: [creepy laughter]
So what do I... What do I do about this?
Is there something I can do about this?
Showtime?
Prize counter?
Something I can do about you?
Put you in the lost and found.
Get in the l- Get in the-
Oh shit, you don't like that do you?
???: Please don't put me back in there.
Mark: Oh yeah. After all you done. After all the people you probably killed.
???: But I haven't killed anybody!
Mark: Oh yeah? But you're not gonna kill me!
What do I do with this.
What do I do with you?
Now what?
Is there like an incinerator or something?
Alright, you know, just to say I did.
Because I feel like I must!
Uh... I'm going to
definitively
I'm gonna definitively
Go through everything again.
Check very closely, make sure I got all these things here.
'Cause if I don't
like
I wanna make sure I do.
Just go through them again, I guess.
FNAF 1. There's three in FNAF 1.
So what I need from FNAF 1 is to find the three ghost coins.
I don't leave until I find the ghost coins to know that I've got them.
You know what I mean?
So there's one under the cupcake. That's a ghost coin.
Okay. There was one in here ish?
Weren't there one in here?
There, there's another one. That's a ghost coin.
Okay, got those.
And then one appears sometimes in that monitor there.
Oop there it goes. Okay, so there's that.
But I got 'em, okay
So those I already got.
Oh.
Hey! There we go!
Yeah! And I know I got the puppet one, so I'm good here.
How did I forget that one.
Oh man, okay but that was one.
I only-There's only-How many are missing?
There's only 2 more!
So, there's only 2 more! I'm only missing 2 more. I somehow stupidly missed that one.
Oh my god, are you kidding me?!
Are you kidding me?!
Oh my god, I know I've gotten that one.
What the fuck? How did I miss these?
There's one behind the head, I know that. That's there.
Is there another one?
Oh-oh my god. Oh my god!
Hey! Listen! Y'know what, actually,
Come give me a hug!
[Jumpscare Warning]
Give me a hug!
Alright, cool this is great.
Holy shit I got all of 'em. Okay, uh, woah.
Woah, hang on.
Aw hell yeah.
Aw hell yeah!
Fuck! Uh hang on.
Well, uh, gotta pick up my scraps.
This sweet delicious butter.
Ah! The wall.
Ah, shit. Oo fuck?
oh fuck?
oh fuck!
What that do?
What the fuck?
What?
Woah, wait a minute. Okay. Um. Hang on a second.
Wha- fuck.
Yeah, shit.
What does that do?
What the fuck does that do?
Don't make solve a puzzle and then give me another mystery?!
Ah shit. Okay um.
Wah, I don't know...
what that means.
Okay, uh, I don't know?
What this is for?
But...
I think that...
I think that's it!
I mean that's all I can think of to do!
There's probably another secret to unlock farther into the game but I don't know what that is, so for now...
that's it.
That's the end of Five Nights at Freddy's VR: Help Wanted.
An amazing game.
Really, honestly, not just an amazing VR game.
Not just an amazing Five Nights at Freddy's game.
But really fun.
Like, I mean the mystery I wish it was better solved but I guess people feel the same way about...
some of my videos.
So, uh...
it's-it was really fun.
Like a lot of fun.
I always look forward to playing this game.
Because of how much fun I was having, so
Thank you everybody so much for watching
If there was a deeper mystery, there let me know down in the comments below
And if it's worth it, I might revisit
but for now, this is the end.
And it-it is kind of serendipitous because it is also the end of my time here in Austin, Texas.
We finished filming the big project.
Actually, today is the big wrap party that we are going to have. So,
Just thank you everybody so much for watching, thank you Scott Cawthon for making such a cool game
and the team that made it, I think Steel Wool Studio
Uh just thank you everybody for being a part of it and really expanding the FNAF universe in a cool way.
And thank you everybody so much for watching
hope you enjoyed it.
Let me know what you thought down in the comments below, check out the other FNAF videos I've got linked in the description or the suggested videos down there.
And as always, I will see you, in the next video.
Buh bye!